governor sysolag giving an update on our
state's covid19 vaccine distribution
just a short time ago
as we head into the final stretch now of
the holiday season
he said things are going well so far but
the community really has to continue its
efforts to slow the spread
and keep everybody safe as we head into
the new year sasha loftus listing into
today's news conference she joins us now
live from the newsroom with what he had
to say
sasha denise yes the governor says so
far the kovit 19 vaccine distribution
is going smoothly with plans to
administer the first shot to those
living in assisted living facilities
next week now so far our state has
administered over 25
000 shots to frontline workers about 20
000 have gotten the pfizer vaccine
about 5 000 received moderna of those
that got the vaccine first they are set
to get their second dose
next week as well one change we are
seeing officials announced today that
tier two of the vaccine distribution
which will start the next couple weeks
will include people 75
and older which of course are most at
risk governor siselek also spoke about
our state's high coveted transmission
rate
and urged everyone to avoid those new
year's eve gatherings
covert 19 is not going to take the night
off to ring in the new year
safety is a partnership and everyone has
a role to play
i am asking all individuals to avoid
large gatherings
i'm asking our workers to practice all
precautions
i'm asking our businesses and local
governments to enforce
all the rules i'm asking that our
visitors respect our efforts to keep you
and our employees safe i also asked the
governor about our statewide pause that
is still in place and whether it's
working or not the governor said our
numbers have really been fluctuating off
and on through the holidays
he said it's important again to follow
the guidelines of that statewide pause
through january 15th
to really see how it works by then
especially through new year's eve